hello everyone welcome to part 5 in our
series on supervised sentiment analysis
the focus of this screencast is on the
module sst.pi which is included in the
course code distribution
it contains a bunch of tools that will
let you work fluidly i hope with the
stanford sentiment tree bank and conduct
a lot of experiments
in service of completing the homework
and also doing an original system entry
for the bake off i'd say that my goals
for the screencast are twofold first i
do just want to get you acquainted with
this code so that you can work with it
on the assignment in the bake off uh and
in addition i guess i'd like to convey
to you some best practices around
setting up a code infrastructure for a
project say that will let you run a lot
of experiments and really explore the
space of ideas that you have
without introducing a lot of bugs or
writing a lot of extra code
so let's begin we'll start with these
reader functions at the top and the
first cell here i just load in not only
os that we can find our files but also
sst which is the module of interest
we set up this variable here that's a
pointer to where the data set itself
lives
and then this function
sst.trainreader will let you load in a
pandas data frame that contains the
train set for the sst you'll notice that
there are two optional keywords include
subtrees and ddo
dupe will remove repeated examples and
include subtrees as a flag that will let
you include or exclude all of the sub
trees that the sst contains by default
we'll include just the full examples but
if you set include subtrees equals true
you get a much larger data set as we
discussed in the screencast on the sst
itself
in cell 4 here i'm just giving you a
look at one random record from this so
remember it is a pandas data frame but
we can get it as a dictionary for a
little bit of an easier look we've got
an example id we have the text of the
sentence the label which is either
negative positive or neutral and then is
subtree is a flag on whether or not it's
a full root level example or a
subconstituent of such an example
since we have loaded this in with
include subtrees equals false we get
this distribution of labels here this is
just a distribution of labels on the
full examples
but of course as we change these flags
we would get very different counts down
here
and then something comparable happens
with the dev reader dev df from
sst.devreader with a pointer to the home
directory for the data as before
and here the subtree distinction and the
dedupe distinction those are much less
important because these data sets
consist just of root level examples and
there are very few if any duplicate
examples in those data sets
now let's turn to feature functions
we'll begin to build up a framework for
doing supervised uh sentiment analysis
and the starting point here is what i
call the feature function it's given in
two unigrams phi it takes in a text that
is a string and what it does is return a
dictionary that is essentially a count
dictionary over the unigrams in that
string
as given by this very simple
tokenization scheme which just down
cases all of the tokens and then splits
on white space
so as an example text if i have nlu is
enlightening space and then an
exclamation mark and i call the
the feature function on that string i
get this count dictionary here which is
just giving the number of times each
token appears in that string according
to the feature function
i'd say it's really important when
you're working with the standard version
of this framework doing hand-built
feature functions that you just abide by
the contract that all of these feature
functions take in strings and return
dictionaries mapping strings to their
accounts or if you want to they're bools
or floats or something that we can make
use of when we're doing featurization
the next up here is what i've called a
model wrapper and this is going to look
a little bit trivial here but as you'll
see as we move through more advanced
methods in this unit especially the next
screencast it's really nice to have
these wrappers around the normal
essentially the fit function down here
so i'm going to make use of a scikit
linear model called logistic regression
very standard side of cross entropy
classifier i've called my function fit
softmax classifier and it takes in a
supervised data set so a feature matrix
and a list of labels
and i set up my model down here and i've
used some of the keyword parameters
there are many more for the scikit model
and then the crucial thing is that i
call fit and return the model which is
now a trained model trained on this data
set x y
it might look like all i've done is call
fit on a model that i set up but as
you'll see it's nice to have a wrapper
function so that we can potentially do a
lot more as part of this particular step
in our experimental workflow
so now let's just bring all those things
together into what is called sst
experiment which is like one stop
shopping for a complete experiment in
supervised sentiment analysis
so we load in these two libraries we get
a pointer to our
um data set and then call ssd experiment
the first argument is the set that will
the data set that we'll be trained on so
that's like train df from before
we have a feature function and a model
wrapper and then these other things are
optional so if i leave assess data
frames as none
then it will do a random split on this
train reader according to train size if
you do specify some data frames here a
list of them and each one will be used
as a separate evaluation against the
model that you train on this original
data
you can set the score function if you
want our default is macro f1
and then we'll return to these two
options later verbose is just whether
you want to print some information and
vectorize is an option that you can turn
on and off and you'll probably turn it
off when you do deep learning
experiments which we'll talk about later
in the unit
the result of all that is a bunch of
information about your experiment stored
in this variable and as because we had
verbose equals true you get a report
here
and this is just a first chance to call
out that throughout this course
essentially when we do classifier
experiments our primary metric is going
to be the macro average f1 score this is
useful for us because it gives equal
weight to all the classes in our data
regardless of their size which is
typically reflecting our value that we
care even about small classes we want to
do well even on the rare events in our
space
and it's also perfectly balancing
precision and recall which is like a
good null hypothesis if we're not told
ahead of time based on some other goal
whether we should favor precision or
recall
so that all leads us to kind of favor as
a default this macro average f1 score is
an assessment of how the model did
here we've got 51.3
the return value of sst.experiment as i
said is a dictionary and it should
package up for you all the objects and
information you would need to test the
model assess the model and do all kinds
of deep error analysis that is the
philosophy here that you should if
possible capture as much information as
you can about the experiment that you
ran
in the service of being able to do
subsequent downstream analysis of what
happened so here i'm just giving an
example that we've got the model the
feature function the trained data set
whenever assessed data sets were used
and if that was a random split of the
train data that will be reflected in
these two variables the set of
predictions that you made about each one
of the assessed data sets the metrics
you chose and the scores that you got
and then if you do dive in like if you
look at train set it's a standard data
set x is your future space y is your
labels vectorizer is something that i'll
return to that's an important part about
how the internal workings of ssd
experiment function and then you have
the raw examples in case you need to do
some really serious human level error
analysis of the examples
as distinct from how they're represented
in this feature space
so here is just a slide that brings all
of those pieces together this is
one-stop shopping for an entire
experiment we load in all our libraries
we have our pointer to the data and then
the ingredients are really a feature
function and a model wrapper and that's
all you need in our default setting
point it to the train data and it will
do its job and record all you would want
for this experiment i hope in this
experiment variable here
there's a final piece i want to return
to that vectorizer variable that you saw
in the return values for sst experiment
and that is making use of what inside
kit learn is called a dict vectorizer
and this is really nice convenience
function for translating from human
representations of your data into
representations that machine learning
models like to consume
so let me just walk through this example
here i've loaded the
vectorizer and i've got my train
features here in the mode that i just
showed you where here we have two
examples and each one is represented by
our feature function as a dictionary
that maps like words into their accounts
you can be more flexible than that but
that's like the most basic case that we
consider
when i i set up my vectorizer in three
and then i call fit transform on this
list of dictionaries
and the result here x train is a matrix
where each of the columns corresponds to
the keys in the dictionary representing
a unique feature
and the values are of course stored in
that in that column so this feature
space here has been turned into um a
matrix that has two examples zero and
one there are a total of three features
represented across our two examples a b
and c
uh and you can see that the counts are
stored here so example zero has one for
a
and zero for uh one for b and zero for c
and example one has zero for a
one for b and two for c
so that's recorded in the columns here
you can of course
undertake this step by hand but it's a
kind of error prone step and i'm just
encouraging you to use dick vectorizer
to handle it all and essentially map you
from this which is pretty human
interpretable into this which is
something your models like to consume
there's a next there's a second
advantage here which is that if you use
a dick vectorizer and you need to now do
something at test time
you can easily use your vectorizer to
create feature spaces that are
harmonized with what you saw in training
so as an example if my test features are
another pair of examples with a
different character
then i can call transform on the
original train vectorizing from up here
and it will translate that list of
features
into a matrix now the important thing
about what's happening here is that it's
going to package the test features into
the original training space because of
course those are the features that your
model recognizes those are the features
that you have weights for if you've
trained a model so it's important to
call transform at the space and as an
indication of one of the things that's
going to happen here is notice that in
the test features my second example has
a brand new feature d
but d is not represented in the training
space we have no weights for it it's
simply not part of that original
training data set
and so the result is that when we call
transform that feature is simply
alighted
which is the desired behavior as we're
translating from training into testing
and it noticed that the dick vectorizer
has simply handled that seamlessly for
you
provided that you remember at the second
stage not to call fit transform that's
the number one gotcha for this interface
is that if you call fit transform a
second time it will simply change the
feature space into the one that is
represented in your test features and
then everything will fall apart and your
model
as trained from before will be unable to
consume these new matrices that you've
created but provided you remember that
the rhythm is fit transform and then
transform
this should be really a nice set of
interfaces and of course this is what
sst experiment is doing by default under
the hood for you